alors comme vous savez on a beaucoup
beaucoup parler de référendum
d'intégrité de chartres lors de cette
campagne électorale mais année après
année élection après élection la santé
est au coeur des préoccupations des
électeurs tous les sondages le montrent
jean philippe robillard à scruter les
propositions des principaux partis à ce
sujet très instructif deux minutes et
demie on écoute ça et quel est votre
préoccupation à sentir oui je souhaite
que tous les québécois est accès à un
médecin
j'ai très très très préoccupant pour
tout le monde selon le sondage que nous
avons réalisés en début de campagne
pour vous le problème principal du
système de santé et l'accès aux médecins
famille alors comparons maintenant ce
que vous proposent les partis les
libéraux vous promettre d'ajouter 44
groupes de médecine familiale de créer
50 super clean est couverte ses jours
sur sept et de former 2000 super
infirmières en disant c'est ambitieux
c'est intéressant mais ce que c'est
réaliste
j'ai des doutes le parti québécois vous
promet un médecin familles d'ici la fin
le pq vous aussi créé 44 nouveau groupe
de médecine familiale et ajouter 150
professionnels de la santé dans les gms
france pas qui a dit dès qui va changer
la dynamique fondamentalement au 5e on
mise beaucoup sur ce qui est sûr les
acquis actuels est complétée surtout la
ligne des gemmeurs des groupes de
médecins familiaux la coalition avenir
québec promet un médecin de famille pour
tous les québécois d'ici quatre ans et
des groupes de médecine familiale ouvert
7 jours sur 7
peu de propositions concrètes 1 on parle
pas d'infirmières par le board y ouvrir
les gmf de sept 7 jours sur 7 depuis
plus longtemps
mais où est ce qu'on va prendre les
médecins donc donc peu de propositions
concrètes peu de propositions réalistes
québec solidaire propose d'ouvrir les
clsc 24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7 et
d'embaucher 800 nouveaux professionnels
de la santé d'ici cinq ans on veut
vraiment faire de se laisser la porte
d'entrée
c'est très ambitieux parce que les
scellés c'est de ce point de vue là
depuis 40 ans 45 ans a été plutôt
difficile dans cette mission là donc on
a beaucoup d'ambition on veut investir
et également beaucoup d'argent mais on
perd de semences de 400 millions par
année à terme
donc c'est très ambitieux donc beaucoup
de promesses mais maintenant c'est à
vous juger ici jean philippe robien
radio canada montréal